a new report just released this morning
accuses one of the nation's largest car
retail chains of selling used vehicles
with unrepaired safety recalls the
Public Interest Research Group looked
into 2400 used vehicles at 28 auto
nation dealerships nationwide it claims
one in nine one in nine had safety
recall issues including problems linked
to deaths and injuries CBS this morning
consumer investigative correspondent
that's Erin a Warner has been looking
into all of this Anna good morning good
morning in 2015 auto nation said it
would no longer sell used cars with open
safety recalls but a traversed course
the next year and perc says it's been
looking into how many unrepaired used
cars are sold to consumers but this
issue isn't limited to auto nation we
checked in with a floor at a car dealer
we met three years ago who says it's
still a problem nationwide in Lake Park
Florida dealer Earl Stewart walks
through a lot filled with cars that he
owns but refuses to sell because they
have defective Takata air bags if I
can't sell a car that I was sell to my
own family to my customer I'm not gonna
sell the car Stewart estimates he's lost
close to six hundred thousand dollars on
those cars over the past three years
because he can't get the parts to fix
them we have to hold those cars until
the Takata airbag is available to fix it
so I'm suffering a huge amount most of
that half a million dollars plus is from
his appreciation but other dealers do
sell cars with safety recalls a new
report from the US Public Interest
Research Group surveyed 28 auto nation
dealerships around the country and says
of 2400 used cars for sale one out of
nine had unrepaired safety recalls some
were to kata airbags and General Motors
ignition switches linked to injuries and
deaths recalls Adam barber co-authored
the report these recalls range from
explosive Takata airbags to steering
malfunctions to seatbelt problems that
could put the lives of drivers
passengers and others on the road at
risk even before the purchaser got home
in 2015 auto nation said it would no
longer
sell any vehicle used or new with an
open safety recall we're just gonna put
the customer first and a customer's
safety first
that was former CEO Mike Jackson on CNBC
you better care about recalls I think
the industry has to get its act together
around recalls and we want to do our
part but a little over a year later
AutoNation reversed course and resumed
selling vehicles with active recalls
Jackson told automotive news with the
Trump administration there's no way that
that issue is going to be addressed from
a regulatory point of view auto nation
advertises that these processes is
worryfree and they're not worry free if
I have a car with the Takata airbag in
it that's something I'm probably pretty
worried about auto nation told us it has
not had the opportunity to see the US
PIRG report but disputed its accuracy
saying it repairs the cars if it has the
parts or holds the car as if instructed
to by manufacturers for cars it does
sell with unrepaired recalls the company
said they sell them with full disclosure
but Democratic Senator Richard
Blumenthal who's pushing legislation to
outlaw the sales of used cars with
unrepaired defects says disclosure isn't
enough disclosure is really no
substitute for repair the dealers who
say disclosure is a substitute for
repair ignore the plain facts that
unsafe vehicles are a menace not only
the passengers and drivers but to other
motorists auto nation says it fully
complies with all laws and regulations
regarding recalls and says any
suggestion that it is knowingly or
deliberately seeking to mislead
consumers is entirely unfounded so I
know what do people need to do to make
sure they don't get one of those cars so
the thing to do is you need if you're
looking at a car to check the VIN number
that's the vehicle identification I've
never done that do people get that yes
you even go to our website we are
posting the link to the government
website where is a VIN number Anthony I
don't even know where it is I do know
where it is I do
hood and I think it's right there in the
- and I often under the windshield on
the left hand side right in front of the
drivers there's a very long number on a
piece of metal yeah it's one of those
things you need a piece of paper to
write it down breaks down on your iPhone
or whatever but you can go to the go to
our website we're linking to
safercar.gov where you can go and enter
the VIN number and you can research to
see if your car has or the car that
you're looking at that you're shopping
when you get serious about a car check
this before you sign on the dotted line
for sure because you may not you may not
want to take that risk
okay so then number check it yeah check
that it's you know my insurance form all
right I got it thank you having we're
gonna ask you about your VIN number
thank you